des kilomètres de carrière et de
galeries truffe le sous sol parisien
ainsi l'été dernier la police avait
découvert une véritable salle de cinéma
une enquête est en cours
nous avons suivi un groupe qui a
l'habitude de fréquenter ces carrières
qui bravent l'interdît ce qu'on appelle
des cataphiles nous explique pourquoi
une telle fascination pour ces lieux
obscurs coupé du monde
pierre gracieux loïc le moigne étudiants
le jour cataphiles lanoux et en laisser
complice décembre depuis trois ans dans
les anciennes carrières de paris des
expéditions interdite mais l' envie
d'explorer les sources les plus fortes
pour ces grands ados prudence rime avec
plaisir et ce n'est pas donné à tout le
monde de dîner à 30 mètres de profondeur
est vraiment vraiment plein de types de
descendre différentes affaires étant
donné l'étendue du réseau on peut
vraiment décidé de faire une une
descente exploration découvrir de
nouvelles galeries on peut aussi faire
une descente avec des amis juste pour
apprécier le calme ils vivent ces
explorations en aventurier arpente des
couloirs sombres et marche dans l'eau
froide
aujourd'hui si les cataphiles sont moins
nombreux ils restent les tags les
sculptures et les salles aménagées
laissés par d'autres avant de poursuivre
l'aventuré cette bande d'amis signe son
passage ces lettres un tract on va même
pas discret du doubs on va donc deux
présents à 35,10 souvenir notre passage
dans les années 80 la rumeur voulait que
de grandes soirées soient organisées
cette nuit là il n'y avait pas foule
mais pour ça un peu importe il vient se
changer les idées
c'est un mélange entre
monuments historiques les vieilles
pierres un petit peu d' aventure avec ce
réseau qui est quand même considérable
ça contraste énormément avec notre
quotidien ou ville métro on peut croiser
des gens de tous les milieux dans les
katas et les anciennes carrières
parisienne et il n'y a pas du tout de
barrières sociales quoi les gens qu'on
croise on est tous sur un pied d'égalité
à égalité aussi devant la loi car la
compagnie sportive de la préfecture de
police veille sur ce labyrinthe d'un
milieu qui est très intéressant c'est
l'histoire de paris ces histoires
souterraine de paris je le comprends
mais seulement cet interdit d'y aller
imaginons nous par exemple qui est un
effondrement ceux qui se permettent de
creuser des chatières pour aller
découvrir des salles par exemple peuvent
un jour être victimes d'un éboulement
est là qui peuvent pouvoir les aider
des dégradations des éboulements mais la
police craint aussi d'éventuels
attentats par les sous sol parisien
d'où une extrême vigilance